in der november 2017 hat sich ein
bosnisch kroatische general spektakulär
vor laufender kamera vergiftet soeben
als eine langjährige haftstrafe wegen
kriegsverbrechen busen jagten 1993 94
vom haager tribunal bestätigt wurden
kurz davor war der ehemalige
generalstabschef der serben in bosnien
zu lebenslanger haft verurteilt worden
heute in feuchtinger kompakt ringen um
frieden auf dem balkan
keiner hätte gedacht dass der zerfall
jugoslawiens so kriegerisch werden würde
ein kurzer krieg in slowene 1991 brutale
kämpfe in kroatien 1991 bis 1995 ein
erbitterter krieg in bosnien und
herzegowina 1992 95 und zuletzt der
unabhängigkeitskrieg des kosovo der 1999
durch die intervention der nato beendet
wurde
die bilanz dieser kriege ist
erschütternd an die 130 1000 todesopfer
etwa vier millionen vertriebene im
inland oder im ausland an die 90.000
sind nach österreich geflüchtet wir
haben heute sieben unabhängige staaten
statt vorher einen gemeinsamen
jugoslawien
wir haben slowenien wir haben kroatien
bosnien und herzegowina serbien
mazedonien montenegro und zuletzt 2008
ist auch der kosovo dazu gekommen
die internationale staatengemeinschaft
hat erhebliche politische militärische
und wirtschaftliche anstrengungen
unternommen und die kriege zu beenden
und den frieden zu fördern zum beispiel
waren in bosnien und herzegowina bereits
anfang 19 96 an die 55.000 soldaten
stationiert ende 1999 im kosovo 50.000
um die einhaltung der abkommen des
waffenstillstandes zu überwachen
unzählige politische initiativen allen
voran der eu sollten dazu beitragen dass
hier die kriegsparteien zu einem
normalen verhältnis finden und die
spannungen abnehmen
österreich war von anbeginn ganz daran
interessiert hier einen positiven
beitrag
zuerst auch heute noch haben wir etwa
zwei drittel unserer soldaten im
auslandseinsatz auf dem westbalkan
stationiert an die 750 und der hohe
repräsentant der die einhaltung des
dayton abkommens überprüft ein
österreicher das negative erbe der
kriege ist unverändert spürbar das
heisst sie sich in nationalismus
religiösem extremismus schwierige im
umgang mit der kriegsvergangenheit und
kriegsverbrechen und besonders
angespannten nachbarschaftlichen
beziehungen
die heftigen reaktionen in einigen
ländern auf die urteile zeigen dass die
wohnung des krieges noch nicht verheilt
sind
seit ende der kriege haben jugend nato
den staaten die hand gereicht und sie
zur integration eingeladen
es sollte hier dadurch die spannung
abgebaut werden sollte mehr gemeinsames
entstehen einfach gesagt gemeinsame
sicherheit durch den nato entwicklung
und wohlstand durch die mitgliedschaft
in der eu zur situation heute so wenigen
und kroatien sind bereits mitglieder der
eu und der nato
in der nato folgende situation albanien
und montenegro sind vollmitglieder
bosnien und herzegowina und mazedonien
haben einen kandidatenstatus und der
kosovo hat einen aspiranten status
serbien ist in der partnerschaft für den
frieden strebt aber keine vollen
mitgliedschaft in der nato an
zum stand der eu-integration serbien und
montenegro haben wir jetzt die
verhandlungen begonnen mazedonien und
albanien verfügen über den
kandidatenstatus und posen und
herzegowina sowie kosovos sind
aspiranten zu erwähnen es gibt
konkurrenten die hier an einfluss in der
region gewinnen wollen allen voran
russland türkei und china
ein kurzer ausblick bedauerlicherweise
stehen ende 2017 noch immer etwa 4500
soldaten im kosovo und 650 in bosnien
und herzegowina im einsatz
ich sage bedauerlich weil es darauf
hinweist dass befrieden noch nicht
gesichert diesen diese internationale
druck
einen sicherheitsrahmen bieten muss
andererseits ist die region 2017 wieder
in den fokus der eu gerückt das
problembewusstsein ist gestiegen
zweifellos kann gerade die ju der jugend
vor ort die beste perspektive bieten und
das ist auch die eu die im gegensatz zu
anderen frieden fordert und fördert
österreich wird in der zweiten hälfte
2018 die ratspräsidentschaft übernehmen
und den westbalkan die heranführung und
die integration zu einem wesentlichen
schwergewichts thema machen